hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work man I'm loving this custom story I
hope you are too okay one of you guys
told me that I needed to combine the
aqua ratio with the currency which I
would have never guessed but that turned
it into Arak hydroxide I guess the
currency had was made of a certain you
know metallic compound that needed for
the aqua regia anyway so man I would
have never guessed that but apparently
if I want to progress through this
custom story I'm gonna have to see aha
there we are Oh Oh be very careful with
this is it supposedly extremely
explosive okay be very very gentle
uh-huh uh-huh and I need to put this by
the door with the boards and then throw
something at it okay it's all it's like
I'm actually quite concerned because
there's no music now not even the
breathing but I do hear the breathing in
here whatever that is okay so let's hope
the game does not crash I still can't
see a bloody thing I've got the gamma
turned up actually okay so if I take a
book I wonder if a book will be heavy
enough I don't know da missed I'm such
an a-hole sorry for this the the string
of obscenities in the last one I usually
try to ah oh I didn't expect that to go
instantly okay yeah sorry for the string
of obscenities I usually try to keep
away from that what is this but you're
not
why why do I deserve that I found a
piece of the orb ha ha can't move I
can't move I know about I'm done okay
can you count more time when I run away
what the hell
wait I'm here I was okay not okay
hold on hold on the shard has fused with
my body how can I remove it without
ripping my flesh maybe I don't want to
remove it
Oh God where am I going what am i doing
now
I still can't see what am I do it oh
there's fleshy goop all over the walls
this didn't happen to Daniel wait they
said those something else in this room
too something oh hello that oh wait how
old how the F will I get out if I go in
there got to be careful about this see
you you come with me you get in there -
yeah if I jump in there I wouldn't be
able to get out okay uh-huh uh-huh what
is this up her up a pair of her gorik oh
no oh no I still can't get out come here
come here come here come here box come
here come here come here come in good
thing I planned ahead usually I don't
plan ahead like this come on come on get
in here get in here thank you thank you
geez okay so now that I have the thing I
don't know what I'm supposed to do with
the thing I'm like gone
I play whoa okay so what am i doing
about this oh okay I'm being guided no
I'm not I can't go either way what the
hell oh hell it exploded all over me I'm
like about to lose my mind here I'm
going pretty much batshit insane okay so
I go the other way maybe
maybe baby maybe yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes go out out out out out down down
down down down down
ha ha out out out out out out out out
out out album moraines quill moving
almost imperceptibly slow finished last
of the lines completing the inner
triangle it had taken him hours to draw
the glyph but he had made no mistakes
mathematically it was perfect
alright I am losing it what is this
what does this do okay so this is
supposed to do this is that what I was
supposed to get and I'm gonna I better
calm down I might complete a puzzle and
I might need that for later
oh that lovely lovely lovely lowly music
Oh freaking ha
no oil I can't see behind me goodbye me
goodbye goodbye goodbye me
goodbye me goodbye me buy me oh [ __ ] oh
my god oh god
ah Baba's
ah
Oh run for my life I was running for my
life what was I about to do I was
crawling on the floor
Alex I guess I'm not supposed to go in
that room maybe okay let's try this
again
holy crap I mean a lot of custom stories
I've tried to make the chase seem
dramatic that was horrifying okay so
maybe I'm supposed to take the first
right okay there's a monster he gets
obliterated I gotta go this way okay so
now there had to be a reason that door
was open yeah there had to be a reason
that door was open but there was no way
for me to do anything about it yeah that
gets blocked up and then I come in here
and hide in the closet yeah perfect
yeah I'm gonna be totally safe here I
don't know
did I make it did I make it
I think I made it yeah I honestly didn't
think that would work at all oh man uh
okay so now I gotta clear this out of
the way and keep running I'm guessing oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy come on get out
of the way kid I like it all the way
oh there's [ __ ] goop on the ground
[ __ ] come on
ah get out of the way get out of the way
get out of the freaking way I got places
to go people to see
ah balls I squeeze through there ah da
[ __ ] gal oh I bollocks
come on uh-uh-uh-uh I'm as a Clark again
Isaac Clark would not do well and I need
you oh [ __ ] hell ah what the [ __ ] was
that oh I'm not supposed to hide in the
closet I'm put to immediately try to get
all that other way well I'm an idiot
let's try this again shall we with more
gusto sorry I'm a frickin idiot
but at least I'm entertaining okay so
immediately take a left then immediately
take another left man
if the darkness was this persistent when
Daniel was going out and he'd never
would have stood a chance I mean come on
he's got whoa not that one that's one
that's one gotta get out get out get out
get out of the way get out the way get
all the way get all the way come on come
on come on go go go go go let me do
thank oh we okay
Oh
let me come on come on come on come on
come on up the spiral stair guys we I
think I made it oh no I didn't make it
I'm not made out of the woods yet
Oh God Oh God I'm not moving forward why
am I not moving forward okay there we go
there we go there we go there we go
are we good are we good
okay I think I'll leave now and the son
had that I'm supposed to see what's this
is water here am I supposed to get some
water for the water bucket no okay no
okay just checking just checking all
right Oh got pal a letter from London
Maureen flipped it open curiously
recognizing the name Hart live on the
envelope
what could a renowned intelligencer like
hartleb want with a small-time Alchemist
like him good question a buddy man sorry
sorry that took me a couple tries there
okay the darkness is not gonna follow me
I don't know okay
so which way do I go now that Way's
blocked off that ways back where I came
what do I need to do I need to find a
way to get the orb out of my body why
did it fuse to begin with why me why me
okay I've been in here before
hello hello cockroach I have no quarrel
with you okay there's nothing in here I
guess I have only one way to go now that
that other way blocked I should have
realized all right back towards the
flowers which grow in the darkness for
some reason lovely lovely darkness oh
hey
the haunted flowers are now open they're
now open to me tell me your secrets okay
what was in here anything of importance
there's more potage I know that maybe I
need to blow something else up wait oh
there's something in there
tinder box I've now have two tinderboxes
fog they do not want to give me
resources okay this is still haunted yep
okay I won't take to breaking the game
just yet
I don't wanna I don't trust you I'm
gonna bake some more Oh Tasha Scotians
and blow you to hell up oh come on okay
so yeah I'm [ __ ] I crush you how do
you even know I'm here
how do you even know who I am huh okay
gotta get boxes I don't know how this is
gonna work cuz everything seems to
explode oh maybe that was like a
preventative measure for people doing
this before it was ready to do ah maybe
because the way the box is kind of blew
up all over the place I don't think it
could have happened so here we go into
the light
trusting this [ __ ] well anything to
get out of here once we were out of the
tunnels there was no sign of the shadow
the stranger offered me a safe haven in
London he said he knew what was going on
I knew nothing about him but he saved my
life
reluctantly I took him up on his offer
Charles Longden is this Daniel chapter 2
all of that was just chapter one and I
now know there are seven chapters oh
damn there's gonna be a good custom
story there's like worthy of being a
sequel to the game I mean okay there's
my Eric hydroxide wait ah now I have two
Erik hydroxides
and a lantern with no oil and now I have
two lanterns a wide still no oil so now
I have two useless objects oil oil oil
no oil yeah no oil I saw I'm just
staying with this weirdo in London
Daniel lived in London at Mayfair let's
see what's going on here
I do not mind it Oh Samuels uh-huh
uh-huh okay all right whatever whatever
you say Samuel that sure doesn't sound a
lot like Daniel hey hey okay there's got
to be something in one of these drawers
that I need I mean I'm gonna look
through everything because I desperately
need oil they're not gonna give me any
oil are they okay where does it go okay
that's a private study that's where he
is but that's not where I'm going first
I need to find other dammit I'm running
a time I hate ah okay I want to play
more what Braemore oh I blame are hella
box
i wad a key play hating in here anything
anything anything anything anything okay
I was also told that chapter 2 is where
the new monsters are hey cuz everything
up until the end of chapter 1 was you
know that same grunts oh nothing really
to worry about there okay well it's
surprising that all the doors are open
anyway okay let me read this one last
note and then I'll finish up here
let me make sure hang on okay nothing
there nothing there okay
here we up while strong acids can be
very useful they're easily weakened over
time by the materials they consume I've
developed a fairly strong reactant for
crystallizing metals from acids it takes
very little of the agent to bond and
nobler metals such as gold but a higher
concentration of concealed extract
lesser metals such as copper temperature
control is everything blah blah blah if
done properly the metal will crystallize
and it can then be filled mu removed by
filtration or evaporation but alright
then that wasn't very informative for my
purposes all right so anyway that's all
for now next time I will start the
meeting with Samuel so thank you all so
much for watching hope you're enjoying
this cosmic Tory I am absolutely loving
this I hope this guy gets a job with a
frictional games or some because he is
amazing whoever worked on this old team
amazing so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
cookies swear damn door